we're in Sydney Australia next to the
famous opera house Brady our video
journalist is from Australia
he's never been into the Opera House and
I haven't been inside yet either but
he's challenged me find something
chemical to say about the Opera House so
I looked at the famous ceramic tiles
that covers the roof
they look nice but I don't see any
interesting chemistry there but then I
remembered there is a famous chemist
Borodin
Russian chemist who wrote operas
as far as I know he may be the only
chemist who wrote operas and he wrote
famous opera called Prince Igor so he's
now really famous for his music but he
also had some quite interesting
chemistry and he discovered a reaction
of aldehydes called the aldol reaction
which I and my students have worked on
we published the paper about it quite
recently but I think it's an important
point for you to realise taking borodin
as an example that chemists are often
very talented people they don't just do
chemistry they do other things as well
right music sometimes perhaps paint
pictures write books whatever I
sometimes listen to opera but it's not
my favorite form of music I have a
colleague who's professor at Nottingham
who's really very keen on opera
I prefer classical music I think without
the singing but I've only been to an
opera once or twice in my life so I
can't claim to be an expert on operas he
said chemists can be multi-talented and
have skills beyond chemistry
what's your hidden skill that we don't
know about
I think I'm just obsessed with chemistry
and I wouldn't claim to have any other
skill apart from chemistry